hello we're glad you joined us for this
live webinar applications of counterflow
centrifugal elutriation revival of an
old tool I am Judy O'Rourke of lab
routes and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab routes the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by Beckman
Coulter life sciences Beckman Coulter
life sciences develops manufactures and
markets products that simplify automate
and innovate complex biomedical testing
more than 275,000 declan culture systems
operate in both diagnostics and life
sciences laboratories on seven
continents for over 75 years our
products have been making a difference
in people's lives by improving the
productivity of medical professionals
and scientists supplying critical
information for improving patient health
and delivering trusted solutions for
research and discovery to learn more
about Beckman Coulter life sciences
please visit
www.cannainsider.com/careers even tation
just click on the support button found
at the top right of the presentation
window or report your problem by
clicking on the green Q&A button at
lower left I now present today's speaker
Anisha rocky a PhD a postdoctoral
research associate in cell and molecular
biology at st. Jude Children's Research
Hospital after completing a master's
degree in virology dr. rocky joined
professor Timothy chambers at the
University of Arkansas for Medical
Sciences in 2011 for her graduate
studies she earned the PhD in
biochemistry and molecular biology with
her work studying mechanisms of cell
death induced by microtubule inhibitors
in primary acute lymphoblastic leukemia
sells a ll in collaboration with dr.
Walter Hillman at the MD Anderson Cancer
Center dr. rocky learned about the
technique of centrifugal elutriation
using Beckman's je6 glue creator rotor
in 2016 she began postdoctoral work in
Joseph T at Freeman's laboratory at st.
Jude Children's Research Hospital
working on development of anti-cancer
strategies in hematological and solid
tumors her current research focuses on
targeting anti-apoptotic bcl-2 family
proteins as a strategy to improve
survival in al l and neuroblastoma dr.
rocky will now begin her presentation
thank you Judy for that introduction
hello everyone thank you very much for
attending this talk after dimension and
ensure directly I am a postdoc in dr.
document lab at changes and I'll be
giving a talk titled applications of
counter flow fantasies and elutriation
abbreviated as CPE so as a revival of an
old tool and I'll explain why I'm
calling it at revivals and the next
slide but before I proceed I wanted to
clarify the difference between a new
creation and Center for the very
creation for elutriation is just a
technique to separate small particles
suspended in a fluid I sped into
different sized groups by passing an
increasing flow rate to the Elimination
Chamber in elutriation particles were
suspended in a moving fluid which can
the liquid or gas however in case of
entry really creation it's very similar
to recreation except back the fluid is
pumped into the rotating separation
chamber that converges into an outlet
tube and we'll see the details in the
comments line so before I go into the
technical details of elutriation I would
like to share some light on the history
of the technique of centrifugal
elutriation this is a technique based
back to 1948 when the first operators
that explore the differences in
velocity sedimentation for the
separation of cells by concur streaming
quantification work described by general
the Beckman instrument company later
modified the instrument and named it
Allah created and down the process
centrifugal le creation and if you would
look up on PubMed he would not a large
majority of the reported publication
using this technique almost ninety
percent where until consultant or even
before that so after that the use of
technique has dropped drastically and
missing technical skills necessary for
funding and operation of this instrument
is partly to blame for direction in
users of CCE
our counter fuel center facility
creation however several areas of
scientific research can still benefit
tremendously from the tools and
therefore this tool is a need of
survival so we'll talk about the
principle of CTE or counter flow
centrism
in creation GE can separate twelve which
different cell fibers which is the basic
principle of CTE the greatest work sir
that the cells are introduced into a
chambers and they are under the
influence of two opposing forces one is
the centripetal force and the other one
is the fluid velocity for counter flow
the centrifugal force drives the cells
away from the axis of rotation whereas
the fluid velocity drives itself to
watch the axis of rotation therefore
these two forces act in opposite
direction and thus attain an equilibrium
based on these two forces inside the
chamber first in the new creation
chamber identical in position where
these forces are equal the key factors
dictating the equilibrium position
other cell diameter and density so as I
mentioned the two forces that act upon
self in the chamber so in this figure
you can see that in the first a section
the fat cells or sample is suspended in
a buffer and they enter the chamber then
the sedimentation tendency of particles
is balanced by counter flow and the
uttering and equilibrium
depending on the self rises and then the
flow if we increase the flow or counter
flow we can cause the elemental
particles to early create from the
chamber and the smallest cells which are
near the exit will therefore they you
create or come out first followed by the
logical and hence by collecting
different fractions of self the
subsequent increases and contests lower
breaks begin separate cells of different
cell sizes this technique needs a lot of
optimization for example if you've got
to use this technique on a new cell type
you have to optimize a lot of conditions
before you proceed process of the
creation requires optimization depending
on sulci elutriation buffer employed and
the specific apparatuses the basic
formulas used which can help you with
the optimization is the Stokes law
according to which FB or sedimentation
velocity is given by this formula which
you can see on the screen here R is the
radius of the particle joking around
density of the particle go m into
density of the buffer and EJ is the
velocity viscosity of the buffer first
sedimentation velocity is proportional
to cell diameter and density and since
tonic diameter or the radius is raised
to the second power it contributes more
significantly
this one gun shows the basic component
of the CET II system the in fact after
the first made ad and one aspect or the
other but as I mentioned this is the
basic components of the CTE system in
this the stroboscope is placed and fixed
at the bottom of the centrifuge the
centrifuge is hosting the rotor that is
running with constant speed the pump is
turned on and sterilization takes place
by running to 70% a canal to the system
followed by a physiological buffer to
remove traces of ethanol the
physiological buffer is then replaced by
the elutriation fluid at an initial flow
rate here you can use 10% bleach instead
of M peoples and ethanol as well the
cleaner around also serves to remove
bubbles from the system and as I will
mention ahead that removal of bubbles is
an important critical step of operating
this instrument the loading chamber
serves as a sample mixer and in its
bypass position traps small remaining
bubbles and compensate on filtration the
bypass valves helps to remove the
suitable bubbles from the sample mixers
chamber
and this is a real instrument attentive
ability creators which I personally used
in my lab during my PhD work and good on
the left-hand side is the front view
where and this is the pump and which by
which we use to control the flow rate
and this is the top view this is the
saturation chamber so you can use CC for
different applications I'll take the
example of certain pronunciations ICCE
to describe the whole technique the
recently reported that primary acute
lymphoblastic leukemia or a ll itself
they undergo death in either g1 phase or
in entries when treated with when
Christian and other microtubule
targeting agents and please being
primary cell we were not able to
synchronize them using the traditional
synchronizing agents such as double
condom block for different other
synchronizing agents so we started
looking for other alternative options
for synchronizing them and that's when I
came across the idea of centrifugal
initiation the ability to separate a log
cells into different cell cycle phases
by CC II was instrumental in reaching
the conclusion the rotor we used for our
experiment was Beckman je6 literally a
tail rotor in this webinar I'll describe
the technical details and offer
practical tips for the application of
PCE to the preparation of finally ll
cells and different cell cycle phases
and these steps remain almost the same
for other purposes as well you just have
to optimize it fine-tune it depending on
your cell types and the factors I
mentioned therefore dr. rocky your
question has come in about that last
slide I'm hoping to posing right now
mention the country
ii-in synchronising leukemia cells which
are suspension cells
what about adherent cells can CCE be use
for them as well so that's a very good
question um the CCE is very good
technique for all the suspension cells
like AML áall however a given cell types
for potential problems due to their
propensity for clumping and possibly
appearance to the surfaces of the tubing
and an occlusion alliteration chamber
and those should be investigated with
caution I personally would not recommend
but if you can give it a try and if it
works with your system you can go ahead
with it but as I mentioned for the
reasons above caution is needed
thank you and moving to the next slide
or this is experimental design to
investigate interface elders in ll cells
the reason so I wanted to know how cells
are dying in specific phases of cell
cycle when treated with one of the
chemotherapeutic drugs called been
twisting so the idea was to isolate or
obtain cells in specific phases of the
cell cycle g1 42m phase and then treat
them with them christian and follow the
cell death pattern but as i mentioned i
could not separate the south in the cell
cycle phases using classical
synchronizing agents so I use the
technique of contra fitted into creation
which is based on the principle of cell
size differences and the cells they
increase in size as they proceed to the
cell cycle yourself in g2 RN phase would
be larger and the cells in S phase and
they would in turn be larger than the
cells and g1 3d but unless the protocol
caps required for a successful execution
of CCE are a la creación first step is
preparation of a new creation buffer and
materials second assembly of value
creation crystal
then climbing of the alliteration system
followed by preparation of the cell
sample introduction of self ample into
the loo creation system and collection
abstraction followed by flushing of the
alliteration system and finally analysis
of fractions and collections of
different schools to make sure the CPE
worked ok I will be describing each of
these steps in little bit more detail so
the first step is preparation of a new
creation buffer and materials
penetration buffers that the one I used
was Hanks offered hand balanced saline
solution which has been already met and
was implemented with 2% fetal bovine
serum and 1.6 grams per liters of tunic
call 6/8 - sponeck acid dye potassium
salt or MTA then I laid then I labeled
50 ml conical fields for selection of
fractions so that there are tubes
labeled wash 1 and wash 2 fractions one
to 20 and the last year body uses as
stop so it's also a 23 tubes where
labeled dr. rocky we have a question
about this slide as well what is the
world NPA any elutriation buffer so MTA
imparts the negative charge to the cells
as a result of which it prevents cell
clumping so it's an important agent to
prevent cell clumping which is very
crucial for successful in the creation
run because I mentioned it's all based
on differences in cell sizes of the
cells would plump the whole cell quite
difference would be thrown off you can
use any chemical which would do the same
thing instead of Andrea thank you the
next step is assembly of their you
creation system this can be a little bit
tricky just based on reading this
however if you buy the instrument from a
specific place those people can also
help you with
family so basically what you do is for
the strobe assembly should be installed
into the advantage a 26 at XP I
centrifuge which is the 1g route so that
the power pod is spread out of the
chamber to the port on the left side
with strobe flash lamp which is on top
of the centrifuge should be at the front
of the chamber so that it will line up
with the viewing window when the
centrifuges closed this will allow you
to look at the cells roughly when the
sender cells are under the process of
elutriation next the JT 5.0 rotor should
be set straight down onto the centrifuge
drive hub and secured with a t-handle
hex wrench but a daughter is secured a
quick-release assembly containing the
new creation chamber counterbalance
locating seal assembly and a mounting
plate can be placed into the rotor it
can sound a little complicated by it's
very simple to do once everything is in
front of you anyone can do the assembly
then next the flow system should be
assembled using a variable speed pump as
I showed in the previous figure on the
left hand side we had a pump and tubing
to pump buffer into the recreation
chamber and collect buffer as it fills
out of the alliteration chamber lastly
turn the centrifuge on and set the
specifications necessary for the
experiment such as name of the rotor
temperature duration of run
acceleration and speed the front here is
used to set your flow rate for the
number how I mentioned the opposing
courses centrifuge centrifugal force and
the flow rate the font is used to
monitor the flow rate whereas the
centrifuge speed is your will monitor
your centrifugal flow rate you can keep
one of these as constant and change the
other one to mu-2 yourself next the
system should be flushed with autoclaved
water
so this is the priming of the new
creation system first before the
interview self into the system we have
to go to prime description for that we
use 5% which we always needed 10% bleach
to flow through all to release bubbles
and back pressure this also sterilizers
the whole system stop the centrifuge and
inspect the chamber for any leaks then
you have to make the system should be
flush with auto plates water introduce
elutriation buffer and allow it to flow
to the system to flush out the water and
then recycle the buffer to the system
the finally the viewing window needs to
be adjusted so that the recreation
chamber can be seen at the currency and
the reason you want to do even if again
we have another question from the
audience it is popped up why you run
autoclave water after running reach
through the elutriation system sure
so bleach can lead to formation of
precipitates from the new creation
buffer which may lead to clamping of the
cells and can also cause harm to the
cells first the reason you have to flush
out all the leftover bleach from the
system using autoplays water and then
only the introduced the recreation
buffering to resistance it's great thank
you
now we have come to preparation of the
cell sample we count cells and obtain
around 300 to 400 million cells in 50 ml
conical tube is note that these are a ll
crime little cultures the cell number
may vary depending on the cell type
you're working with annual requirement
pin down the cells add 12 mg for 3
minutes after it of growth medium and we
suspend cells into any 5 ml of
alliteration buffer by pipetting up and
down gently you have to make sure of
strip is very gentle because you don't
want to damage the cells in order to
reduce cell clamping it is essential to
pass cells twice through a 25 gauge
needle this will make sure the cells are
not plumped you can further take a look
at the cells under microscope to make
sure the first look independent of each
other and are not clump and after that
now it's time to introduce the cells
into the education system and then
collect the fractions
princess the cell samples are introduced
into the sample into the system by
pouring the salt into the reservoir tank
which has the recreation buffer
recycling through the system the
progress of the cells entering the
system can be tracked why are the
viewing window which is on top of the
centrifuge so you can see the cells
entering the chamber even when the
centrifuge is closed and running then
for once if you are comfortable that the
cells have entered energy change in the
chamber you can start collecting
fractions and you can change the speed
or as I mentioned you can either keep
the speed constant or the flow rate
constant and change the other side or
the parameter in this case I change the
speed and the subsequent changes and
speed a collective fractions
I collected fractions of 50ml each and
once all fractions are collected so the
first two fractions where my wash one
and wash two that's when the smallest
debris particles come out of the
chambers followed by 20 fractions of the
cell and then I stopped centrifuge and
collected the last fraction and called
it stop fraction which usually have
selected gates finally you have to clean
up the system so that it's ready to use
for the next time you want to use it for
that
after the centrifuge has a stop
completely flush the system with
autoclaved water followed by 10% bleach
the
can also use 70 chips and economic turn
off the pump remove the input and output
holes from the quick relief assembly and
pull out the pins from the anchoring
table if you are a centrifuge we are
using only for electrician purposes you
can leave the assembly in the fantasy
itself however more economical would be
to use further through the centrifuge
for other non-elite creation purposes as
well so in that case you have to take
out the whole assembly every time after
you and reassemble it every time they
need to leave now it's time to know
whether the elutriation you just carried
out worked or not for that you need to
analyze the fraction and collect the
pools so to begin with a sponge that
each fractions as because in G for five
minutes I boarded researchers and
aspirate off a new creation buffer for
the g1 phase pool I refer standard
fractions collected in the food range of
788 G to 661 G there were fractions 1 to
5 in 1 ml period for the g 2m say i
researchpoint attraction collected in
the speed range of 387 G and 333 G which
were fractions 17 to 20 now the fraction
people can be optimized so initially
before pulling the fractions I had
already done cell cycle analysis on each
of these fractions so I knew that
cooling fractions 7320 is giving me good
amount of G 2 n face cells so you can do
that on your own individual expect of
experiments and then we can find out
cooling which collections will give you
a good pure population of that specific
rate of those markers and then I spun
down the cells as above
iso standard internal of growth media
and take a cell found
the self-id meter we used to take the
cell count also gave us cell viability
and cell diameter so we knew that the
diameter of fractionated fractions where
more than a diameter of the earlier
fractions which is a very early
indication that the new creation went
well and the good person viability also
indicates that the trousers did not have
a detrimental effect on the cell but for
ensuring that the diffusion went well we
have to take an aliquot from each pool
to analyze for DNA content wire
forbidden iodide stain and flow title
metrics analysis this will tell the cell
cycle phase each fraction belong to the
remainder of each pool can then be huge
for further experiments this is
representative result of one of the new
creation runs we carried out as you can
see on the top top left corner the cell
diameter is given on the y-axis and the
fraction number is given on those excess
food the fractions 1 to 20 and you can
see that the cell diameter is increasing
with each increasing number of fractions
so the fraction collected thought
earlier they had smaller cells are
nature's as against the fraction
collected later in the alliteration
process which has higher diameter so
that this is an early indication that
everything went well then this was the
cell cycle analysis of control cells
prior to initiation and they have a our
good proportion of g1 phase cells as
faces and g2 are M phase cells as shown
by the DNA content by probably
dehydrated staining
now these are the pooled fractions from
the elutriation so one on the left is
early fractions which is actually side
to eight they had all the early G one
from itself and you can see the content
of joins as base cells is ninety five
point four percent as against 71% in
prior to elutriation so we had been able
to get a pure population of Ali G one
faithful after elutriation by pooling
fractions five to eight similarly the
intermediate fraction which are obtained
by pooling fractions thirteen to sixteen
had a third population of late g1 and at
Facebook and finally the late fraction
fraction nineteen to twenty it had a
very good population of sg2 and n phase
and but mostly of DNA foreign DNA
content and the further verified this
result for Imanol blot analysis for
different cell cycle phase markers and
that further confirmed these findings
then we use these pure cell cycle phase
cells to carry out that experiment to
find out the cell that pattern induced
for the interest in individual cells so
i'm not going to go into details of
those experiments because we are talking
about just across s of elutriation even
anytime go back to my paper and look for
the details but it's talking more about
the process of elutriation
there are strong steps during the
process which are very critical and
challenging clear has caution has to be
taken to make sure that both are catered
for example it's important to ensure
that the cells aren't mono dispersed and
not slumped at the start of the run then
optimization of the conditions of
counter flow rate and water speed is
very important but before you start any
elutriation
you have to run the loot creation few
time you can start with the Stokes law
to calculate what counter fuel rate
would do to your condition i Fermi the
NIDA deliberation maximum time I spent
was an optimizing the whole thing once
everything was optimized it was easier
from there on then it's important to
ensure the components of the system are
clean and free of debris and finally a
ward introduction of air bubbles into
the flow line so you have to go to be
usually is transparent so you can see if
there are any air bubbles in the tubing
and if they are you have to make sure
you remove them before you introduce
yourself into the system this technique
has a lot of advantages but I have
listed the most important advantages
here the first are not subjected to
harsh conditions of chemical treatment
on nutritional deprivation which are
usually used to synchronize the cells
and it can be recovered in excellent
yield essentially unperturbed this
contrasts with self synchronized by
chemical means which may Harbor drug
induced damage in for example a recent
study using env for cells derived from
acute myeloid leukemia blood directly
compared centrality creation and other
methods including arrest with serum
starvation hydroxyurea or treatment with
a cyclin dependent kinase on inhibitor
ro2 3:06 and it was found that in
treated cells and cells arrested at
comparable figures appeared similar with
respect to DNA content and fibrin
expression however when the proteome was
examined major changes in protein
abundance particularly circulated and
arrest specific proteins were observed
in the arrested self and not in delhi
created self at equivalence cell cycle
position to be resolved clearly
highlight digitally
of CC for the production of unperturbed
cells and emphasize that caution should
be taken use when interpreting data from
cells synchronized by other means
this method is still regarded as one of
the best way to prepare unperturbed
synchronous in structure for cell cycle
studies and even alien cultures and
finally the first obtained by this
method can be cultured for many days
without any signs of distress which we
control we took the Frog and monitored
the viability for few days after the
recreation was performed and the first
they're doing fine however no technique
as there are is the doubt any limitation
for the yes there are some limitations
to be settings as well for example the
most important is that it works best
with cells that significantly increase
in cell size as they advance yourself
Michael
so console for example such as only in
Bionic cells the cells progressively
decrease in size as the device so this
technique will not be applicable to
those cells however those type of cells
are very rare so it should be applicable
to majority of the so the cost of the
specialized centrifuge rotor and
accessories can be very high however you
can collaborate with us some labs which
already have the systems with them and
that way you can work on the cost factor
as well then scheduling and condensing
conveniences for alliteration runs
typically take five to six hours
followed by time needed if the first
options are subsequently mediate for
other experiments so this can create
some scheduling inconveniences if other
people are also requiring gentlemen you
have to plan everything in advance and
reserve the instrument again at once if
you plan to run daily creation
dancing and finally this method works
best on selves look around our oval
shape this method has a lot of
applications more thematic and I strappy
one second another question has just
come in how do you find out the cells
are increasing in size as they advance
through the cell cycle so yes but for a
given population of cells in suspension
this kind of established initially and
easily by examining the relationship
between DNA content and side scatter
side schedule is dependent on cell size
so both parameters can be measured
simultaneously by flow cytometry after
bavarian iodine staining and a linear
relationship between side scatter and
beginning content provides confidence
that cell size increases the cofactor
advance and the CP we have the potential
to separate cells based on our faculties
if you do not get the linear relation
then it's a matter of concern okay thank
you so much for that then talking about
the application the most important of
and widespread application of French
people alliteration so far has been
unperturbed synchronization of animal
cells and East cultures so also although
CCE is correctly and enabled in
suspension cell cultures it can also be
applied to sub cellular fractions for
example nuclei Tommy Rhine
PD cells have been successful if I
separated using this technique the
central elutriation has also been
reported to separate hematopoietic cells
mouse tumor cells testicular cells and a
variety of other specialized cells from
other cells and interestingly recent
advances are expanding users to the
federation of cells from healthy versus
cancerous tissue and to the production
of specific cell guides for
immunotherapy
the curve you can enrich for self within
a population of immune cells because of
difference in cell Pfizer's using this
technique the back I'll contains the top
the picture on the top left is Phoenix
which divides itself so I thought it was
perfect for this presentation because
centrifugal elutriation is it needs a
revival because of all the advantages it
has there lies a huge untapped potential
of CTE in making significant
contributions to wide area scientific
research and this old tool is therefore
worth dividing in current times the
ability to prepare cells and duration
specific cell cycle phases by CTE has
greatly facilitated cell cycle research
in both East as well as mammalian
cultures a successful method for
obtaining energy allows cells in
different phases of cell Quackers within
CCE was just described and similar
principle of operation applies to other
cell types with that I would like to
thank you everyone for their attention
and I will be happy to take any
questions thank you thank you dr. rocky
for your presentation we adjust some
questions during the presentation so if
we weren't able to address your question
we will follow up afterward I would like
to once again thank dr. rocky for her
presentation do you have any final
comments oh I would like to thank to
everyone all the audience for patiently
listening to the talk and if you have
any more sections even after the webinar
get for free to email me I will be more
than happy to help you this technique
definitely needs some guidance to learn
and I'll be happy if you have any
questions for me dr. Hillman from MD
Anderson Cancer Center he was an expert
at this technique and I was fortunate to
learn it come home
so I hope you find some guidance and
you're able to harness all the benefits
each technique has to offer thank you
well thank you again dr. Rossi and I'd
also like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions we would like to
thank our sponsor Beckman Coulter life
sciences for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on demand through February 17th
2018 lab routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye